hi reject nation it's Greg Alba here and
I'm jonald Humphrey we are going to
watch today top ten movies you missed
this summer 2018 this comes from
watchmojo.com you know the most beloved
channel in the world right now Andrew
Hayes patronage a one of our reward
tiers on patreon is whatever video a
question was definitely come and put up
all the youtubes and today comes from
Andrew Hayes a fantastic man he's been
on this channel he's a lovely lovely
tall gentleman is a awesome YouTube
channel as well I should go check out
his movie review guys I'm telling you
it's worth it let's get into it summer
isn't completely full of dinosaurs and
superheroes after all welcome to
watchmojo.com and today we're counting
down our picks for the top 10 movies I
bet you I saw I bet you all wanted this
a lot yes public content every day so be
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
ring the bell to get notified about our
latest videos for this list we're
looking at movies that were released to
theaters between June and August 2018
that received a big-time critical
acclaim but which were largely ignored
by the general newbie going public
register I think one thing we've never
done before
number 10 The Miseducation of Cameron
post nope never heard of it
it's your girl version camp in an
attempt to cure her of her sexuality
based on the 2012 novel of the same name
by Emily M Danforth
oh we didn't hear about this especially
vulnerable to eat it stars the brilliant
Chloe grace Moretz in the title role it
was originally screened at Sundance back
in January where won the festival's
prestigious Grand Jury Prize you're
facing the consequences of your action
oh she's a star
various despite its lack of a paying
audience it's a movie that deserves to
be seen well told story 90s nostalgia
and wit but also for it's beautiful and
timely themes on bravery optimism and
acceptance I'm tired I'm disgusted with
myself it's actually rated pg-13 50
malik elements young actors into the
spotlight foster even no trace will do
that for Thomasin Mackenzie like Cameron
Post Leave No Trace debuted Sundance
before receiving a limited release to
theaters in the summer who taught you
how to read and add pictures me you're
actually quite a bit ahead of where you
need to be it tells the story of an Iraq
veteran suffering from PTSD who attempts
to maintain his rural hermetic existence
with his young teen daughter we should
add a new service
you feel safe living with your dead we
didn't need to be rescued both Ben
Foster and Thomas and McKenzie are
mesmerising in the lead roles with the
latter receiving immense amounts of
praise the film currently sits like one
hundred percent on Rotten 285 reviews
gobbling them up - we tried wearing
their clothes when the house we're
eating the food we're doing their work
we have adapted never ate don't worry
you won't I did once
[Music]
Gus Van Sant's biopic tells the real
story of John Callahan an alcoholic
quadriplegic award-winning cartoonist in
the Pacific Northwest who channeled his
frustrations and unique sense of black
humor to drop brilliantly provocative
and edgy newspaper cartoons the amazing
cast includes mega stars Joaquin Phoenix
Jonah Hill Rooney Mara and Jack Black
and with really balances moments of
sweetness pathos and incredibly funny
yet incredibly dark humor you always be
for everyone especially considering its
difficult subject matter but for those
who do enjoy a good dark comedy this
movie is a must-see well it's just
supposed to be funny
number 7 searching first what I really
want to go find early through computer
and phone screens I'm calling to report
a missing person searching is arguably
the first movie to use it
and come up with legitimately thrilling
inventive results none of this would be
doable without a committed actor and the
versatile cult favorite John show is up
to the challenge
crap they're all evil and relatable ok
we wouldn't quite call it the future of
movies but searching proves that you can
indeed craft a great movie out of this
style is it number 6 and this one dude
roger is one of the most widely beloved
TV stars I give an expression of care
every day to each child
this documentary honors his life work
and legacy and then some it paints a
picture of a beloved and radical yet
complex man it isn't afraid to highlight
Rodgers imperfections and it's all the
more honest and therefore stronger for
it and also beautifully highlights what
made Roger is such an incredible human
being an influential figure for
generations of children and adults alike
this is required viewing for everyone
whether you watched Rogers or not oh and
make sure you have a box of tissues
you're gonna need it when I was a boy
and I would hear about something scary
my mother would tell us always look for
the people who are healthy you'll always
find somebody who's trying to help
number five everybody flourish that
movie over 10 years in the making
screenwriters Raphael Cassell and daveed
Diggs of Hamilton fame began the movie
blurs the line between realism and comic
absurdity by detailing many facets of
modern african-american life and culture
in Oakland California through the eyes
of a parolee who witnesses a police
shooting
Oh seems like gentrification and police
brutality
well definitely balancing hard-hitting
drama social commentary and
light-hearted buddy comedy and it's
succeed many many levels
three identical straw man oh my god it's
three Greg's you're the fourth brother
becoming one the doc details how the
children were raised and then
subsequently discovered each other by
happenstance when they were 19 it's an
intense exploration of identity and the
effects that upbringing and culture have
on individuals and then the story takes
a turn and things get even more bizarre
and unbelievable it's a real story that
towards Ranger than fiction they like
the same things but deep down they were
different number three black claims I
saw it's directed by the renowned Spike
Lee and was released in over 1500
theaters yeah well boots Riley hates it
doesn't deserve a place on as well since
you asked I hate blacks
I hate Jews Mexicans and Irish the true
story of Ron Stallworth a black police
officer who infiltrated the KKK in
Colorado in the 1970s to mini Colorado's
800 it's obviously a very topical film
as its release date coinciding with the
one-year anniversary of the
Charlottesville rally can attest however
it's not just a political movie it's
legitimately both hilarious and
thrilling contains great performances
and is filled with relevant observations
about deep-rooted societal issues all my
commentary is gonna be about this one
yep there it is I actually got tickets
it had to return raid was both written
and directed by Burnham and it explores
a 13 year old girl's final week of
middle school the
lying coming-of-age story and deep dive
into school social life may be nothing
new but it's told with incredible
sincerity and rawness and it's
observations on mental health confidence
and anxiety are utterly topical don't be
weird and quiet it's like I look over at
you and I think you're about to drive us
and we treat or something and then they
get really freaked out and then I can't
get to my friends it's just like be
quiet and drive and don't look we're
inside kids today generation never
experienced an eighth grade honestly
beautiful right someone who can go
through tough times and make themselves
feel better with their advice and
actually do the stuff they talk about
before we unveil it all over one pic
here are some honorable mentions yes my
man sorry to bother you
now ask me number one yes I mean they
already showed an image from it earlier
this one I think so yeah
like at the top you know what they say
about dreaming the darkness fades of
genius
nobody could create emotions like
McQueen number one very serious I saw
this one to kill in the game right now
there's a black telemarketer who puts on
a stereotypical white boys to help his
career as always we'll be getting that
up too right away as he climbs the
corporate ladder and taste success and
wealth his radical friends and
co-workers protest that corporate
culture it was written and directed by
first-timer Boots Riley although he held
the screen here like a veteran without
gloating no power collar
we know there's no amount of money that
make me do that the movie is filled with
fantastic performances and a highly
surreal ambitious filmmaking style that
guaranteed its place is one of 2018 s
most unique and original films if this
movie is any indication boots Riley will
soon be one of Hollywood's most
acclaimed creative minds you
[Music]
do you agree with our picks check out
these other great clips from WatchMojo
and be sure to subscribe and ring the
bell to be notified about our latest
videos oh yeah I saw - what'd I say how
I said I would see 2 or 3 is that - you
killed it killed it man you got to start
predicting every one of these video may
I have seen and I remember what I heard
about the gay side of Chloe that was the
working title for this movie before they
decided to go back to the book I forget
we were doing some video where we
started talking about Chloe grace Moretz
and and how I was I loved her when she
first debuted and lately she hasn't been
that great then everyone in the comics
is like well clearly you didn't see this
education camera poke do you know it's
like no it's obviously on this list
because most people do education so now
if anybody gives a crap about it you
could just direct them to this like well
hey most didn't actually see that movie
and I've never even seen a trailer or
heard of it there were already movies on
here that I had heard a lot about from
many of people but out of all the ones
that this video has introduced me to
it's definitely this movie mis-education
that i want to see the most out of the
ones that i haven't heard of already
that i'm already feel guilty about not
having watch yeah I feel like there's a
Russell Crowe Nicole Kidman movie coming
out that's a very similar plot like a
gay conversion kind of thing yeah where
at the end it's gonna be about just be
gay yeah this is the new like deep
impact vs. Armageddon you know we're
gonna have like a conversion movies at
the same time it's topical you know yeah
dude it is very topical the movies
searching that heard a lot about this I
never saw the trailer and now that I've
seen footage and understand a little bit
more about what they meant by found
footage just a yeah but then seeing like
the different kind of approach in the
style they take with it
this looks like really intense and
really good
and everyone that raised about the movie
John chode I mean like I feel like the
guys never really got in his do you
think welcome to Harold and Kumar do
both of those guys are so much more than
just really cool I don't know what ever
recognizes them for that done so much
and are both pretty especially John
chose is a good actor and this movie man
like oh yeah I'd heard the concept I've
heard like oh it's kind of cobbled
together from different digital sources
yeah this is the first footage I've seen
of it and it really made me wanted to
track it down and watch it especially
this month you know cuz October actually
I'd nursing this movie really mm-hmm
she plays a little Asian I really gotta
keep a lookout won't you be my neighbor
yeah if there's a movie on here that I
feel the most guilty about not watching
it's won't you be my neighbor because
that is the like the most positive
inducing movie I've heard just a
reminder of humanity intolerance a lot
of these movies seem very important the
consistent themes here are about
acceptance and gays okay and being black
is oh my okay yeah you know maybe
there's systematic process Society we
got to address it's crazy to me how when
I step out of this bubble I live in LA
like oh yeah they're like these real
problems out there pockets of the world
that are not like it is around town
where you just see a bunch of different
people coexisting well everyone that
talks about won't you our neighbor talks
about it in the sense oh this is a movie
we need right yeah this is a necessity
that's why I feel bad for not watching
blind spotting is like my sister's
favorite movie of the year I've heard
nothing but great thing people say like
mesh is dark comedy and buddy comedy
I've seen the tree like where's the
funny and exactly they showed here I
haven't seen the actual shooting
sequence and that just looked so yeah
just crushing and intense and scary I'm
just like where is there gonna be
because this just seems like such a
ripped out of the headlines thing like
where would you even
put three identical strangers it's been
like a crazy good year for documentaries
to which I have watched none but I
wanted to and yeah I saw the trailer for
this way back and I am fascinated and
that thing at the end where they're like
it's this really heartwarming story
about how like these three different
brothers found each other but that [ __ ]
gets crazy and I'm like what is that
about it all produce three identical
babies yeah they just had triplets that
are all identical yeah but they're
triplets all look identical to each
other's triplets in that there is not a
love to another set of triplets
scattered those babies all around the
world and now they're on a project to
see if they can get back to each other
form one mega family of identical people
they all look like my cousins hey man if
you want to get a live-action Hulk TV
series going on you'd be no shortage of
doubles I think I want a star and you
know the the scripted biopic of these
guys black Klansmen I talked about this
on Stardust black classroom was a movie
that very much moved me a lot nothing so
funny how like boots Riley's sorry to
bother you is seems to be the most
talked about indie film of the year in
like in the service I run and like he
really ripped this movie apart here or
like a three page essay on why this
movie like he just doesn't like it isn't
with it I get that a lot of this is
fictionalized
it seems to really push that this is a
true story but that being said I still
think the points hit home you know Spike
Lee is a very political guy it has this
nice wraparound in the end of what's
going on today
usually when like you know a movie ends
and they like flash some footage or they
or they like do a text of you know like
here's what's going on the rule the day
like the post it's usually like oh wow
yeah yeah when you watch this movie and
then you see that like five to ten
minutes of footage to cap this off it
terrifies it was terrifying like this is
a movie that has stuck with me I just
saw so many weeks later I never
review for it this was a very I thought
impactful film in Isaiah Washington's
great it Adam driver is incredible in
this movie it's weird because it's
called he's the one who gets the most to
do in the movie okay a white support but
it makes sense cuz he's the one who's
really put in the most dangerous of
situations in the movies that's why he
gets the most chances to shine where
Isaiah gets a lot more subtlety to do
grade eighth grade bo burnham is a big
love for both John and I and first
youtuber I ever really committed to I
just really wanted to watch and I did
have tickets but I forgot something I
come up that we had to go to or whatever
and I was like definitely watch this and
with the feeling of I should have
watches in the theaters this commentary
on social media knowing that Bo Burnham
is the best one to do that out of any
one I know who can make a good
commentary on that and Bo be my personal
friend he really wanted to pack it with
authentic you know uses social media was
talking with my lady about how we have
you know our lives are really run by by
social media in such a Norman that there
are kids who are born into this world
and then I started like looking back cuz
we were born a little bit before the
internet was it and it's not like when
the internet was born everybody's had
Wi-Fi yeah hooked like 20 minutes to get
time and then it took even longer to
load anything beyond the fast like we
tend to go back to that joke of dial-up
social media just wasn't a thing and the
most forgotten about social media
platform the first one that really there
were other ones are the one that made
the most impact was a thing called
myspace yeah and I feel like now more
than ever a myspace movie would be so
essential the song I open that was the
time when we started manipulating how we
formed ourselves on the internet and
started using ways to hurt people get
back at them who was on your top friends
list what you post about and I started
thinking about I can hate social media
and I realize I am part of the
generation
contributed ya through what has made
with social media is today yeah we were
the test dummies that built this machine
partly the way it hasn't made the
demands that they supplied to us and I I
was a contribution I participated and
it's funny because I've gotten older
I've just naturally gravitated away from
social yeah yeah because there are a lot
of things that are they're very
unnatural about it and like through the
scope of a movie like that I can't
imagine what it would be like for a
junior high schooler or an elementary
school or you know growing up with all
this social media around because you
know kids aren't the friendliest people
anyway when you're little even and to
have that mechanized and instantaneous -
and like omnipotent is really kind of
scary when you think about it hashtag
team I pose great at breaking things
down from a psychological you know
emotional standpoint - so it's just kind
of crazy to go the thing I hate I can I
can really flash back and I can see when
it happened yeah oh my god I was witness
to what will forever change society
giving wieck's it's crazy sorry to
bother you I don't love this movie as
much as everyone else like it's a movie
that sticks with you and it's [ __ ]
weird it like it's weird it's a weird
movie you think we see the trailer in
for just like a comedy with some social
commentary it's so much more than that
it's one of those movies I really
appreciate it in there's plenty of
moments that I genuinely enjoy it and I
like it a lot I just don't love it to
the degree that it seems like a lot of
people love it I just have some like
technical film issues with it in terms
of like pacing in the first half
especially and getting a little bit more
wrapped up in what it wants to talk
about than just being pure about its
character I know
la people will probably disagree me on
that I've heard a few people say that it
does have some first film style edges on
it you know they're not like a pristine
first film in some ways it's their times
were myself whole audience ago what it's
just like strange it just starts
happening really
in the theater because III don't really
know what to expect as I've also heard
that like it's stranger than even the
trailer lets you on very much
it's definitely had my curiosity all
these months like before the end of the
year I'm just gonna have to go plow
through this list and I think like he's
Stanfield's amazing in the film I still
think that if it got a Best Picture
nomination I'd be like yeah yeah I
believe it yeah
it's worth definitely worthy of that
like it's one of those films were I
don't love it but I've other people do I
totally get why I would never try to
sway someone in the other direction if
anything I don't want to be swayed in
that direction yeah yeah show me what
yeah all right guys well is there any
movies that should have been on this
list that you just happened to not catch
well you guys can subscribe to the react
nation click that notification bell
check us on patreon and make sure check
out Andrew Hayes's YouTube channels
fantastic stuff I love the guy you'll
love him too
you